and for more on the story I'm joined by
political analyst Tyson Barker from the
Aspen Institute in Berlin
welcome Tyson in fact our the Deputy
Attorney General went on to say that
Matt if Cohen would have to pay a heavy
price for all the violations that he's
made but to what extent does the former
lawyer of a Donald Trump and a close
associate implicate the President
himself let's be clear this is the fixer
of Donald Trump for more than a decade
he's basically like a surrogate son this
guy knows where all the bodies are
buried and what he's done is pled guilty
to two charges where he said he made
illicit payments hush money on behalf of
a candidate that would directly affect
the election that is a criminal claim
and the candidate which was not stated
by name but is clearly Donald Trump this
is a big deal but he doesn't mention him
by a name does that make a difference
not really I mean we know it's it's kind
of like smoking causing cancer all the
indications point to him his only
association with a federal candidate was
with Donald Trump so it is Donald so you
feel that Donald Trump is clearly
implicated by Michael Khan's guilty plea
so what does it mean for Donald Trump
can he be indicted or impeached so there
are two avenues here you mentioned them
indictment impeachment an indictment is
unprecedented it's never happened
prosecutors in the past Justice
Department prosecutors have decided not
to indict sitting presidents for
criminal or civil acts and there's a lot
of precedent for this under Nixon under
Bill Clinton etc so that's unlikely but
not impossible
impeachment that's a criminal process
impeachment which is a political process
is much more possible that's something
that would be adjudicated in Congress
and honestly the first test of this will
be the midterm elections because if the
Democrats win let's say 80 seats that's
going to be something that they're gonna
have a mandate to pursue okay now let's
look at the other case the campaign a
former campaign manager of a donald
trump paul a manifold the Paul Manafort
is another former Trump associate is a
former campaign manager as I mentioned
now he's have been found guilty by a
jury on eight charges the judge declared
a mistrial on ten other counts a
manifold was convicted of filing false
tax returns in connection with millions
of
lobbying for Ukraine dozen we heard
Donald Trump defend manifold but he
didn't say anything about marches Cohen
why do you think that was the case these
are two qualitatively different cases
the White House the president are
feeling the white-hot heat from the
Cohen plead guilty plea and he doesn't
want to implicate himself he's already
gone on a wreckage thing that he didn't
know about the payments that is now
perfect to be false
that's what coincident growth with
palmetto court he has a lot more play
room he can say because a lot of these
associations with the Ukrainian
government happened before the campaign
he's not really going to be directly
implicated so to the extent that he's
trying to make his case in the court of
public opinion it's a lot easier to do
so dealing with men afford looking at
both these cases collectively how
damaging are they for Donald Trump
especially with the midterm elections
coming up in November as you mentioned
we're seeing the drip drip drip between
the Moller investigation between the
mana port case between the the Cohen
case the noose is tightening around a
culture of corruption that was involved
in the campaign that's gonna have
political implications obviously in
November in the elections but it could
also have legal implications we could
see more indictments coming down the
road for people like Roger stone even
for Don junior right Tyson Baca from the
Aspen Institute thank you very much for
that assessment